قلق اوروبي مع استنزاف المخزون العسكري في
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا وقدرات واوروبا
الدفاعيه ربما لن تحميها من التهديدات
وفقا لمنسق الشؤون الخارجيه والسياسه
الامنيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
حرب اوكرانيا بمثابه جرس الانذار لقدرات
الاتحاد الاوروبيه العسكريه وهشاشه سلاسل
الدوري
لكن ماذا انفقت اوروبا على الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه تتحدث عن
ارتفاع حجم الانفاق الدفاعي داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي في 2021 الى 214 مليار يورو
زياده الانفاق الدفاعي تعادل 6% مقارنه
بعام 2020 كذلك زياده الانفاق تشير الى
اقوى معدل نمو منذ 2015
تقرير وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه اشار ايضا
الى حجم الانفاق الجماعي الاوروبي على
عمليات البحث والتطوير لدول الاتحاد
انه بلغ 248 مليون يورو خلال 2021
بعد سنوات من الانخفاض
معدل النمو قارب السبعين في المئه مقارنه
بعام 2020 نصفه لمشاريع البحث والتطوير
انفاقه
464 مليون يورو اضافيه للوصول الى معيار
البحث والتطوير للدفاع التعاونيه الاوروبي
بنسبه 20%
المطالبه بسد الفجوات الحاليه في القدرات
بشكل سريع لتجديد المخزونات وتحسين
الاستعداد القتالي
هو رغم ان مستوى الانفاق على الحرب في
اوكرانيا ربما تجاوز سقف التوقعات الا ان
دول الاتحاد اتفقت على دعم اوكرانيا
سياسيا وعسكريا واقتصاديا حتى تتمكن من
طرد القوات الروسيه من اراضيها جاسم محسن
العربيه